President Biden soaking up the sun while
KS unfolds under his administration's
watch our commanderin-chief landed in
the US Virgin Island of St Croy
yesterday and he will be ringing in the
new year at a luxurious beachfront home
owned by some of his Democratic power
donors sounds very nice don't you think
well anyway it is nothing new for our
commander-in-chief he has spent about
40% of his presidency on vacation and
while the president relaxes on the beach
the crisis at our Southern border is
reaching levels that we have never seen
before unprecedented December is on Pace
to be yet another record month and a
massive new migrant Caravan Caravan is
set to make things a whole lot worse
that is headed in this direction and the
problem has gotten so bad that even
Democrats and the liberal media cannot
ignore this any longer now the mayors of
Denver Chicago New York all blue
Sanctuary cities are begging the federal
government for
help this is unacceptable our city here
in Eagle Pass we've been getting slammed
with 2 to 3,000 people a day and it's
just an unfair unethical situation
what's going on here in Eagle Pass we
feel ignored by the federal government
without real significant um investment
from our federal government it won't
just be the city of Chicago that won't
be able to maintain this Mission it's
the entire country that is now at stake
Denver finds itself right now at Ground
Zero in trying to resolve and resp
respond to the migrant crisis we need
more Federal support to be able to
manage this amount of inflow those who
should have been helping us in
government every step of the way just
critiqued us I am not seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel um from the
federal government and I think they we
can't treat this as a policy we have to
treat it as an
urgency the call has been made and
immigration also one of the top voters
as far as voters are concerned one of
those top ofl issues heading into this
pivotal 2024 election year even CNN
agrees what do voters think about
immigration right now yeah it's becoming
a real top issue here so the top issue
facing the nation look the economy is
still number one it was number one in
August it's number one now but take a
look at the immigration B security it
was just 11% in August look where it's
hopped to now 19% so it's closing in on
the economy the most Google searches for
migrants by state look at all these
States Phil they're all blue States
Illinois is one New York is 2
Massachusetts is three New Jersey is
four Colorado is five and of course
there's been a lot of talk about the
migrant crisis in both Illinois and New
York and it seems like even voters in
those States very blue State states that
Democrats win in general elections
almost always they are focusing on this
issue as
well perhaps part of that is that these
states and these cities are beginning to
really feel the impact because the
migrants have come there Massachusetts a
major problem with their shelter system
now overrun Todd your thoughts well to
that point it's almost like these cities
and states are just realizing that we
are in an immigration crisis whereas
let's be realistic we're in a crisis now
but this problem of immigration has been
ongoing for years if not decades and
just because it's starting to hit their
cities and towns they're starting to
complain about it what I find
fascinating Texas never held themselves
out there as a sanctuary state yet they
are the ones that are bearing the brunt
and when they try to distribute this out
to the rest of the country you know to
those cities and towns that put
themselves out there they're the ones
Greg abin in particular that are getting
a lot of flak from these very very
liberal cities and Mayors and governors
and that is just so shocking to me also
when it comes to Mexico I hear that
they're putting forward a task force to
solve this problem I think anytime you
hear the phrase we're putting together a
TA task force that is a a clear sign
that what you are doing is nothing and
this is just for show final Point mayor
Adams here in New York City is uh by
executive action and executive order so
that always raises some eyebrows now
saying any bus that comes into this area
that's a charter bus must give him 32
hours notice obviously let's be real
that is to interdict that bus because he
doesn't want more migrants here I would
argue Cara Frederick play lawyer with me
here for a moment that is a violation of
the Commerce Clause because that
involves a bus company in interstate
commerce which is their job you are
interfering with that job if I'm that
bus company if I'm the state of Texas I
sue based upon the Commerce Clause yeah
it's not just the buses the plane our
own bill maluan consistently great
reporting on this issue across the board
uh saw this sign at the Tucson airport
in Arizona directing non US citizens
without passports into a special line
for domestic flights all across the
country so the migrants all across the
country now this has really become a
national problem it always has been but
it seems like the leadership in some of
these cities are noticing it now Cara
yeah and we've always said at the
Heritage Foundation that every state is
a border state now because yeah you saw
what happened in Arizona you saw what
happened in Texas now people are feeling
the pain we remember Martha's Vineyard
and how quickly they got those illegals
out of there and this is intentional we
know it's intentional uh 10,000 illegal
border crossings a day probably more
than that that's what that we've
determined and it's not just as you say
a national issue it's an international
issue it's a national security issue
because we know that these are coming
from high-risk countries when it when it
comes to terrorist
when it comes to the these specialized
versions of countries where we know a
lot of terrorism emanates out of that I
used to do counterterrorism for the
government this is a big problem when
you have military age males crossing the
border with no accountability it's a
national security threat I would not be
surprised if we already have sleeper
cells in the United States because we
are not keeping accounts of these people
we are not vetting them we don't know
who they are we don't know why they're
here we don't know what they're bringing
with them we don't know um how many
frankly this is happening and if it
weren't for people like bill maluan and
his tenacious reporting exposing this I
think Americans wouldn't know until the
big one hits and that's what I'm
concerned about as a national security
professional we need to be aware keep
your essay up everybody because I fear
that it might be coming if we don't
clamp down right now yeah Cara really
centering in on that on that issue of
terrorism and that this being a national
security issue and all of these leaders
City and States talking about how this
is really hitting home in in communities
all across the country uh as well as our
our own home homeless and Veterans and
this is just an issue that has a major
domino effect here it does it's a once
again the Democrats not thinking about
the second day not caring about the
second day it's about the agenda the
ideology the mission very much like what
Harvard's dealing with they're not
thinking about what all of this means
and then they just scramble one thing I
can say about Joe Biden though and his
vacations is he's he's the captain
stubing president it's you know on a
cruise ship there's the real Captain
captain and then there's the show
Captain who has the dinners and walks
around and meets the the Cruisers but
they're not really running the ship so
you don't need to worry about that I
mean this is now the world doesn't
realize that we understand that but we
don't know who's running the country and
the agenda attached to something so
outrageous that is putting everyone at
risk you would think even a broken clock
is right twice a day that this should be
stopped because and it's almost as
though it's so bad they're frozen into
not knowing what to do because then I
would again say like Harvard the it it
really kind of destroys the entire
Theory from the start the moment it kind
of proves Trump being right right is
that they have to go back to that
Dynamic uh and I think that's the
problem but many people's lives are at
risk uh a as a result of their uh uh
bullheadedness yeah you know it it is an
election year we're on the cusp of a new
year 2024 and at least one Democratic
Congressman out of Texas is concerned
about what this potentially could mean
for Democrats and and the president as
well take a
listen we're losing Democrats they feel
that the Democratic party that the
president is not doing enough and we're
gonna lose a lot of Democrats and it's
because we're not doing the right thing
at the
border bringing the good doctor here
yeah absolutely I mean he's completely
right how many uh Democrats switched to
Republicans in Pennsylvania more than
30,000 recently that's a sign indication
of where our country is going but you
know what Molly we're breaking records
today records that we're not very proud
of we're going to hit what 300 400,000
migrants in the month of December in the
past fiscal quarter I mean this is
terrible outrageous numbers and you know
it's because we're sending out a message
a global message that we're open come on
down and what it's doing is it's
overwhelming and overflooding the
sanctuary cities the sanctuary cities
are drowning and I can attest to that
firsthand because right here the Port
Authority where the buses come in or
immigrants come in where I work where
I'm going after you know the show my
shift to take care of uh illegal
immigrant patients every day and I tell
you it's heartbreaking some of the
stories that I hear what they go through
we talk about inhumanity I mean I've
talked to a parent a mom of an immigrant
child who came in little girl she was
sick with a parasite that she picked up
from Crossing through the waters um very
sick very unwell we were able to take
care of her and I asked Mom you know
what was the journey like how did you
get here and she had to make seven stops
to get here to get to Mexico and then
you know there was a point where her
daughter was crying she was hungry they
had no food and she told me that the
Mexican cartels threatened to take her
away I had another patient a father came
in with his son and I asked him what was
the hardest part of his journey he told
me that everywhere he went he had to pay
the police the Mexican cartels to pass
through and and that's not to mention
the the stabbings of patients that I had
and I asked my uh immigrant patient who
barely spoke English why didn't you call
911 why didn't you go to the hospital
when you were stabbed and when you're
bleeding and you know I almost broke
down in the room he told me he he didn't
want to be deported he didn't want to
have to go back so this is the
inhumanity that we're putting these
these people through by not securing The
Border Great Point uh doctor and and
these are the fortunate people that come
to to reach you and to get medical care
so uh a horrible terrible Journey hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye mcki
on outnumbered every weekday at 12:00
p.m. Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights